so I'm going to get in game mode muting
alerts this is the first game of my
third Regional Cup and the Armageddon
championship series if you want to learn
more about the event uh there's a twitch
command if you're watching this in the
future on YouTube there'll be links in
the video description
and uh thanks again chess Arena and
World Chess for sponsoring the Stream
and now let's play some chess
playing
um starting with London
playing UVA Berry
who's playing the coffee guy variation
it's interesting Black's kind of playing
a reverse Joe Bava London
with Knight C6 Bishop F5
which generally can come under pressure
early like I already have 95 here
and the problem for black is because E6
was played
the bishop can't return to D7 to
neutralize the PIN
so this already looks really really good
for white
like there's Queen D6
but then I take the Knight hit the queen
discovered attack
start with C3 now I'm hitting the bishop
and still hitting the Knight twice
be to take
I guess there's queen queen D7 could be
interesting
have Queen A4 there
but yeah here I'm winning uh
The Exchange
plus upon
you could take the bishop first
no mercy in this race game
okay successful engine opening on move
12.
material advantage 92
[Music]
this is still a matter of finding some
plan to make progress maybe I should
have thrown in Queen E4 there
there's some plan of playing F3 and E4
yeah starting with Queen A4 and then um
likely trade on e4
also taking away box casting rights
Bishop takes all play F3 if Pawn takes
yeah I mean
nice position to play
still some E4 ideas generally when
you're up the exchange
so when you have a rook for minor piece
one of the main strategies to make
progress is to
look for Pawn breaks to open files
because the only way The Rook took
really the main way for The Rook to
prove the dominance over the bishop is
for a file to eventually open
[Music]
and the file is going to be the D file
are the x-ray vision against the black
king
we might see Bishop C4 okay
a free Bishop
very short-lived triple Pawns
I'm throwing Queen A5
yeah The Rook is going to start snacking
Rook D5 coming
u414 so so I appreciate the raid
yeah if you're just joining this is the
first game of the Armageddon cup
tournament on chessarina.com
Armageddon championship series
this is um one of the regional cups
still working on my terminology
yeah at this point the the goal is to
just Checkmate the king as quickly as
possible
uh just going after the D6 Pawn
if black defends I could take the pawn
right away okay here I will
yeah where's my Force mate
Queen C5
as Maiden two or three
or maybe four
yeah King A7 Rook B5 checkmates
Rook B5 was slightly more efficient than
Rook B4 because
that's a longer Mouse movement okay
um nice start to the tournament
I can switch the scene here
I'll go back to
the tournament
oh I'm playing grave
I played grave before
another feeling of deja vu
okay muting alerts
there we go I was not expecting to play
grave as early as the second round
so teamwork
very strong Grand Master he's a world
record holder
of um a blindfold chess
I forget the exact number but he's
he had some insane record of playing
like over 50 games
simultaneously blindfolded
um I played it many times before
we had a leechas bullet match recently
which I got the better of him but okay
this should be interesting
um it's taking a little bit of time
here we go
he's very like creative player too so
we're starting with um
Eastern normal opening
might go for Cambridge Springs
wait I played him I played him in
Cambridge Springs where he played some
Bishop E2 move
we're not going into it though
maybe he remembers that game
and play B6
and play one of these setups
kind of like a reverse Kali
where uh
Bishop B7
yeah we're employing similar setups the
main difference is
whites white already has an hc3 and C4
I'm keeping my c-pawn back and I have my
Knights on D7
which does
block the or it doesn't block my Bishop
one major idea is E4 for white
which can lead to a lot of Trades we do
see E4 so
wondering I'm gonna have Bishop B4 in
the end
take take take Bishop B4
let's go for this
I'm not sure how great this is
king of flying yeah
give this move
between each four likely then Bishop E7
it's already a success to take away
casting rates
oh what to do Bishop E7 and queen G7
Rook d8 although then that walks into 95
and C5 is like a major
idea to Contessa Center
which unfortunately I can't play right
away
actually considering E5 here A5 A4
I'm thinking the queen would be best on
B7
and then eventually Pawn Z5
wow H4
so he wants to destroy me
um
I have Queen E4 to
maybe induce a queen trade
H4 is a very grave type move you might
also want to play Rotation Rook G3
keeping the time advantage
maybe Queen E4 now
I mean we trade Queens
looks okay
hmm
sometimes when the opponent attacks on
the wing it's best to respond in the
center
95 is a fine move okay we could trade
and then C5
and Bishop D6
let's start with Bishop D6
and keeping some tension
not sure if I actually want to take the
Knight though
[Music]
I think I should take
and Knight C6 Rook D7
wow
so if I play G6
and D5 could happen
1894 with an F3
9 E4
idea Knight C5
I'm just trying to hold my ground
in times about level
The Rook wants to join the party like
rookie Yates
we see rookie three maybe I take first
and play F5
foreign
might happen
but now Knights Knight G3
I'm gonna have four move
confusing position
Bishop C5
we can't have seven two
no king of cyborg have six
good move
foreign
oh wow
can't take the pong
another five's coming which like rookie
seven out of five I covered G7 which is
very important
same trick
to play this
you can't take the wrong as 97
I can take
preventing 97
.
it should be winning
attack well you can't meet me okay let's
go
okay try and stay focused here
I felt like I I played relatively clean
that game like avoided blunders
um manage time well
and it's one of the key things
the key um goals for
for Blitz is to not plunder and just
manage your time
H6 G6 okay
fishy opening
foreign
[Music]
idea
[Music]
thank you
and get away with E5 here
looks playable
some E6 idea as well
this has a much different feel from the
previous game
not the most mainstream opening
I'm going for just immediate destruction
here
take Bishop G6
and there's Bishop c42 but Bishop G6
looks nice
so King G8 it's made into King f8
um I think I should start The Rook D1
because if I play Queen E6 immediately
there was Bishop D5
as there's Queen C8 here
now Queen C4
how is block defending
I just want to meet on F7
there's not too many ways to defend
if Knights okay there is E6
defend what if I play
Queen B4 I could take on c72
I mean there's not a three and so many
moves
kind of like net of three
idea 95
also some idea to Castle to
I don't mind that trade
okay something like rookie six
and there's Bishop
oh there's a cool idea actually Bishop
D6 and then
take take Rook da take
let's go for this
no there's no no need to be that fancy
Rook E6 or Rook uh Rook D6
it's like there's so many options to
try and put the hammer down
it's just a matter of choosing one
yeah so here I can take and then take on
E6
so I'm threatening
threatening Rook F6 and queen F7
unlock defends
hmm
really not so simple
take take check
I think I get away with 94.
92 though
and keep the pressure I gotta imagine my
time too
a queen's tied down into F7
or H7
tick
just play this move
I'm gonna win C5 next I think I'm just
second guessing myself too much here
this should be a simple win
foreign
just a matter of winning material
and take the Rook whenever
thank you
yeah that's a good try Queen A5 hoping I
don't see the the fifth rank
honestly I'd maybe try the same thing
yeah so Bishop f8 Queen F5
would attack the rook and the Knight
yeah there's no stalemate tricks as long
as this Pawn can move
my groogy 2 it's good try
A5 only legal move
okay
[Music]
GG
yeah I mean took some work to punish
what
um which should be a very dubious
opening there
so that's
three out of three
okay just trying to get in the right
mental state
I think he's a D4 player he's capable of
playing a lot of things though
[Music]
okay he plays plays E4
um
forget if I ah yeah he's played this
against me before
um
and just play a dragon formation
oh what's the line
Castle
really needs to spend some time to learn
these these anti-sicilians
a knight C6 go for E5
a little bit counterintuitive with the
bishop on G7 but
um it resembles some King's Indian
structure
it's a little bit out of my comfort zone
though
calculating Bishop E3 B6 and then play
Bishop E6 next
threatening Bishop A6
which kind of looks like a move of
X takes takes takes takes takes I lose a
d file and then
so I guess Bishop B7
oh wait a minute he wants to win the
pawn
maybe I have to go over that
hmm
already down a lot of time to
so I'm calculating a line uh Bishop F1
or Bishop Bishop F1 King F1 rookie Rook
D1
I play Knight F6 hitting the E Pawn
I think it's okay
because e-pawn's not easy to defend I
also covered Knight D7 that line
wow
so let's just go back
still under a little bit of pressure but
I feel like I've very close equalized
I'm down almost a minute
five
still under pressure here
foreign
probably a good move
and crazy move
wait can you I made him one Rook T8 man
that's an insane move
uh to do
I can't move the knights
A5
A5 and Rook C8
foreign
well played like I resign
oh
I don't think I have a defense
after Bishop E8
like how does it stop Rook do you I mean
maybe there's a better approach
and download this PGN
and learn from my mistakes
I've already played two out of the three
GMS
it's a gray of Oparin and
Jose Martinez
so I'll likely play with our hands at
some points
I just wanna try and refocus after that
previous game
manage time
[Music]
try and play cleanly
on London opening time
okay this transposes into more of a
pierce opening
Rook E8
F3
I'm actually not sure of the
correct move here but F3 is usually
pretty natural
so Knight C6 Bishop B5 is a useful
resource
foreign
game recently against Darius swearts
and on title Tuesday
maybe H4
although E5 can I play E5 now
E5 because black can't take
this one's an H5 it gets weird
if take takes the D file opens maybe
Vlog can take Knight H5
and it leads to a confusing position
but clearly lock is the one under
pressure here
wow 94.
looks like that one's a piece for me
yeah up a clean piece here still
pressure too
all right there's three attackers on the
on uh the D7 Bishop
if I take the queen first
I think I'd prefer Knight B5 first
idea being that C7 is very weak
that's also a forking Square
like Queen D4 Rook D4
so looks like another opening success
uh yeah Knight C7
and I mean I was already up a piece
and I'm winning the exchange uh
one of the Rooks so I'll be up a full
Rook for a pong
unless there's some trickery but
now the night moves I take the bishop
first
there's Bishop H6 check but F4 King B1
okay now it's just a matter of technique
no mercy
I could take
and go after the queen side pawns okay
not sure if I played this person before
name sounds familiar though
they're an arena GM
I think I have played this person before
yeah we went into some Dutch
I think they beat me last time if I'm
not mistaken
I'm just playing a London
I want to play C4 but not allow a bishop
B4
okay playing positionally Queen B3 some
C5 idea
like maybe C5 right away
Rook C1 first
Rook D1 was another option
yeah now I'm thinking C5
take take
just trying to pressure the queen side
Bishop D5 Bishop C4
I really want to take give away my queen
get the pawn to C7 doesn't work though
Queen B4 doesn't work
Queen C2 it is
still a lot of pressure with the C file
Bishop D3 don't mind the trade
and but I can't really play B5 so I
think the C file is guaranteed to open
now the C5 opens and I should be in very
good shape
I guess there's Knight C6 so
my king might stay in the center like if
we see Bishop F3
yeah Knight C6 so take and Bishop B5
Maybe
so I'm hitting the Knight and the pawn
Bishop D6 is a resource I should
keep an eye out for like maybe I could
have played it previously
some idea like H4 H5
uh Knights
95 is maybe coming
so Bishop D6 first
okay at this point I'm just going for
for full domination
a knight's pinned now Rook D7 but then
Knight D5
could win the pawn
I'm looking for better but
pawns upon
95 Rook D3
maybe should be three coming
two
everything's still under control the
king's actually pretty safe in the
center
a nice Shield upons
and now I can take
him Bishop before
taking Bishop E5 actually
trading Bishops
it would be nice to actually open the D
file Target the
double d-pawns
that's a move
a four
still takes work
I have to be careful
King F3
times close to level
foreign
resourceful
[Music]
up a pond so
oh wow
still not simple
just leaving the pawn tension
okay Rooks are now connected
take and double up
not sure the king is just gonna go to F6
that's a good move
King G3
really not sure how to handle this
King is so safe but so is box King
it feels like I'm making progress though
trying to come in from behind
some Rook tension
and queen moves I play something like
Queen E7
threading Queen G7 mates
I was just thinking about this
I think I just go into a winning Kingpin
engine
so I give away the queen
but I win the right back
a resulting ending I just have a past
peep on
looks like I might win on time but
yeah there we go
there may have been other ways to win
this like more quickly but this is a
fancy way
like Rook F7 it's a simple win
[Music]
okay
oh they have four points okay so I guess
I'm like pairings were weird
wait what happened to the there we go
okay
E6
English opening
transposing into maybe Queen's Gambit
play this bishop D6 sign
foreign
H3 I don't think is
great positioning for white because it
prevents opportunity for Bishop G3
Queen C2 good move
I'm very tempted to play G5 here
allows a sack maybe just for V8 first
opponent playing solidly
E4 again
could move
if I take
and C6 is a bit loose actually
and probably have to
maybe this was the wrong approach for me
and what to do
before
could be interesting
that loses a pawn though
not thrilled here
you have to take and then play Bishop D5
I'm still losing upon yeah
or am I
some tricks
okay that's a very good sign I mean
queen
C8 and offer the trade
Rook C4 looks nice
okay I felt under a ton of pressure a
few moves ago but now
feels a little bit better
actually a question which Pawn to take
with
I'll take this way it's my dear Rook B8
oh there's a really funny line
I don't think it's gonna happen but
I'll try and set it up
it's not happening
in G5
I was hoping the king would go to C3 but
what's this move
rookie four
and there's F5
hmm
oh the light ones come to C3
good move
the bismon E5
might go for the trade
I could start with F5
no I'll start by taking
it's probably just equal
okay I was trying to calculate rookie
three King F5
I'm down a minute man
moving a little bit too slowly
I like the position though like there's
it should be a two result game I'm not
in risk of losing
some idea H4
yeah rookie two I just taken King E4 and
when the kingpong ending
I was thinking just each four here
so I'm threatening to take in rookie
three
take take then the King has a path up
King F4 coming
yeah light's very passive here that's
probably the the difference
cattle wind is just by peace activity
so rookie two tick tick ER
I was thinking F5
there's a few approaches
I've got five is cleaner
okay so take King F3 King H2
wait
why am I struggling with this
yeah
just making sure my King's not getting
trapped it looks like it is trapped but
uh license looks wrong here king of
three I play King G1 King F1 I play King
G3
pre-move King G3
and the the winning technique is to
quote unquote stalemate the white king
only the b-pawn can move now only the a
pawn can move
and there we go okay
that took some work opponently really
well like out of the opening
okay
Allen Sicilian
the sign this is what adibon played
against me
so I'm supposed to take
and some Knight E5 move
yeah I looked at this after I lost
adiban okay he's preparing
Bishop E7
at six might be the move
this is where my prep ends
Bishop B7 looks reasonable
because Knight C6 can be thrown in okay
here I'm thinking taking with Knight
to take
I'll take with knights
probably B6 Bishop B7
it looks like a solid position that's
really the goal
to
just hold my grounds
I mean 95 probably coming at some point
some Knight F4 ideas
and he6904
eventually targeted G2 with the bishop
yeah so something like Knight G6 here
looks solid
Bishop B4 is a good move kind of forgot
about that
um
yeah I have to defend the bishop
Queen C7
[Music]
Knight B5 Queen C5
if I get the chance I probably want to
play A6
and prevent all the Knight B5
shenanigans
A4 was a little bit unexpected
the opponent wants to attack
I think he's six is potential settings
where
[Music]
um
have to be careful here
thinking Queen like Queen F4 is
interesting
Planet 4 is also just insane like take
take take Queen F2 King each one
not entirely sure what's going on there
okay take take
off King H1 you also have 93 in the end
to take
I think it's winning a piece
so C4 is now a threat
always repeats
yeah simple
simplifying a little bit
es a bit misplaced on G6
[Music]
Rook D5
and this first
I'll manage my time
H6 would probably be useful to throw in
somebody in 97 Knight G5
interesting
Rook D5
I didn't calculate this fully but 96 I
think I just taken Rook E8
this game will probably come down to a
Time scramble
so I want to play Rook d8 I get the
chance
you know I trade all the Rooks probably
have to
to fight once
oh there's a night before in the end but
then Queen B3
A6 is a bit loose
oh there's Queen A6
I don't have anything
it gets messy though Queen A6 Queen B2
Queen B6 94.
I want to play Queen D1 King G2
I'm gonna have to go for counter play
oh wow that's a good move but I'd take
maybe it's not so good
okay Queen D1
threading metaphor
some mating ideas
F3 is maybe playable
I might start so confusing here
F3 Queen G5 idea Queen D2
time is very much on my side which just
looked at the clocks
yeah Queen F3 Knight H4
E5 is also a resource
taking time because I have time
[Music]
in the D5 first 95
E5 first
[Music]
really close to winning
hmm
I'm trying to move fast
[Music]
oops
foreign
[Music]
a slightly dirty flag there
oh it's hard to move quickly in the time
scramble
um I think my point was offering a draw
I think that this will sound I'm not
sure though
but um
okay not really much of a break
next game starts soon
okay
D4
okay
opponent one of the French I want a
London
play this move
yeah this is a trendy line 92 Castle
Queen said
and queen queen G3
between G3 there's Knight H5 I have E4
E4 is awaits I go
there's cases where the queen goes to G3
to pressure G7 and C7
but E4 is just natural move taking over
the center
and Bishop D3 looks natural
over defending the pawn so my queen
and Knight are no longer tied down
yeah C5 so I mean Bishop D6 is a move
like I get taken
I also play D5 there's a few moves here
maybe you want C4
hmm
not 100 sure how to handle this
D5 is probably the principled approach
I take
I gotta move quicker
um
I think I'll go for this
Bishop D6 just a more concrete line
wow C4 immediately if I take
some crazy compensation here
that's the latest V2
I think it's okay though like Queen B4
A3
like E5 D4
E5
it's kind of a risk
I think it's okay
don't have a great feeling about this
position
[Music]
an ip596 is an idea
it's still not easy for black to attack
Eric B's coming
I play something like H4
maybe just A3
and this move
oh no I'm getting a delivery now
uh
ah the delivery driver is calling me
let me try and finish this game first
I'm about to hang over Rook
okay this is like really close to losing
I think it's already losing I might
resign and like deal with the delivery
but
uh what to do 23 it's not over though
I think B3 is coming too
the player G4
opponents played well to fight back
foreign
for
really
take on G7
after this game I need to call the
delivery driver later
being patient
page three
threatening needs
the queen also defends C3
wow twin defends
insane Bishop D3
still might be close to winning
look at this move
I know I'm losing the knights
it's insane position
I'm losing
I was so crazy
some Rook G1 idea
still fighting actually
crazy enough
I've hung a bishop
it's over
crazy move this game okay let me call
this
driver
oh no it's automated no my delivery and
my king
a phone survive this is spreading made
in one
yeah I can game
we have hold music I know people can
hear this but it's hold music
oh yeah so anyway uh this might be a
little bit weird
let me mute myself on the call so they
they can't hear what I'm saying
I'm just listening to
[Music]
okay
okay let me focus on this game first
okay all right that sounds great
um can they can they just text me when
they arrive or call me
hi can they text or call me when they
arrive
okay sorry about that
I'm getting one of these deliveries
today that like it needs to be signed so
oh what to do
okay uh I didn't lose too much time
there
um I think I have a reasonable position
take I just trade Queens
in Knight C6
wait
97
okay
let me try and focus
our refocus
I like Knight C5 I'd see five of those
c7s a bit loose
and stick with Bishop
maybe I'll do that
trade Queens I take with Bishop put the
Knight on E6
and the E6 anyway
okay
I gotta move a little bit more quickly
just realizing I'm playing without sound
okay
oh I don't like this position
now what to do
C5
[Music]
I'm getting completely outplayed
I play Bishop D6
no
if I take Knight C5
that's worth a try
this also loses material
yeah
and take with Bishop maybe take this way
it's actually not so bad like it could
be a lot worse
so I'll take the bishop
to opposite color Bishops
Knight survives on C5 I mean B4 may be a
move and then I take the bishop
preventing B4 if A3 I play A4
I have to be really careful here
Rook C5
h5h4 is a plan
foreign
[Music]
let's play something like this
I just want to stay alive
rookie five so I lose upon I used to
have Bishop C5 as an idea
Knight D4 is also an idea
hit the queen identity two maybe
it's running F2
hmm
take
trying to stay alive here
not easy
I don't want to simplify but I think I
have to
foreign
foreign
moves
okay
oh dear
[Music]
okay
just have to check if they're
arriving
okay let me Focus here
at some point during this game I might
have to like go away for a few minutes
hopefully it's uh it's okay though
this is a slightly annoying line too
hmm
am I playing
I have yet to play Opera
I guess is some
bit of luck
Thank You Phillip
I see you
appreciate it
this is already probably not that great
for white
um of Queen G4 the problem is Rook F6 is
coming
I'm gonna go for C4 try and stir up some
counter play
B3 C4
Queen D4 first
how many points do I have I have eight
points total
um
it's so hard to say Focus doing my best
though
it takes I take on e4 okay some G4 idea
I'm not really ready to take on D5
because I takes on C1 and then I get
mated
let me start with G4
that was a great move
take
if I take
take take
went a little bit wrong here
maybe this move
there's lines later where I'd win the a
pawn and I get the passive on
a very confusing position though I'm
gonna go for this line
we do simplify a little bit
I think black has to take on C1
I'm not getting mated here Rook H4 I
have
King G3
and we trade on D5 I take with Chuck and
then the king
it's a lot easier for the king to
find a safe place
so it's King h8
okay I'm getting a call I have to take
this
hello
hi are you here
okay
uh
that's not so bad
still have 50 seconds left okay
the time's about level
yeah the trying to absorb what's going
on here so the
Rook is a little bit stuck
it's a move though
it's gonna be another time scramble
let's start with
how to do this
F4
I think I should be safe with the g31st
like King G2
and later F4
running A7 now
you know this position takes a lot of
patience
and queen's gonna get constantly hit
but as long as like you can keep the
time advantage
how do I escape the Rook attacks
Queen D1
what round is this
we need two I want to play A5
and put the queen on B1
I have eight points
[Music]
all right this might be the last round
I think opponent offered me a draw there
threatening something
on each eight I think this is the last
round
okay very close to winning on time
also might be winning in the position to
like E4 F5 coming
foreign
let's go okay oh
uh back to tournament it was last round
as last round wow
so I
I finished with two losses
tied for double grave just passed me
wow Graves only loss was to me wow